so I had another question about apple
cider vinegar and is it okay
is it safe to use on your hair so let's
talk about that
so there's many benefits of taking the
outside of vinegar internally for your
digestion for your blood sugars and you
can also put it on your skin topically
because your skin is slightly acidic
okay and I'm talking about the scalp as
well so by using apple cider vinegar
correctly you can do several things
number one you can help to restore the
pH of the scalp you can actually give
your hair a nice shine and it can also
clean up some of the residues that you
get when you use shampoos and
conditioners and as a side note I highly
recommend getting a filter that can pull
out chlorine and fluoride from your
water because those two chemicals are
halogens and they're very reactive on
your skin which can give you all sorts
of acne type issues they could damage
the hair so here's what you don't want
to do you don't want to apply the
opposite of vinegar directly in the
concentration that it normally comes in
because that could damage the hair you
want to use a dilution of one tablespoon
for 16 ounces of water and you don't
want to have it sit in the hair for a
long period of time you want to
basically use it as a rinse after you
use the shampoo and conditioner if
that's what you use
and I also recommend not doing every
single day maybe once or twice a week is
fine and I think you're gonna notice a
huge change in the quality of your hair
go ahead and try it and then comment
below if you're liking this content
please subscribe now and I will actually
keep you updated on future videos